okay hi everyone we are continuing our
review of discrete computation for
version 13.
and we had looked previously at these
lovely coloring functions
where had we got to we had been looking
at planographs right
and
dominator trees
which we got a little bit stuck on
right because the documentation wasn't
fully updated
okay
um
okay and we want to understand whether
dominator tree and that whole lingo
is the best and right lingo for that
is that the only name that those things
are known under
the only ones yes that's kind of alice
as far as i know and i looked actually
okay
so let me understand so so this is
dominator so this is like
this is like a transit of reduction
graph i mean it's the same general type
of idea
i mean not it's not doing the same thing
but it's the same
okay
directed graph from the root vertex v
dominator tree
what is the relationship between this
and a spanning tree
okay please don't do it this way please
when you're going to do this just put
the freaking graph in here don't say g
equals
yes yes that's the first round of the we
don't do that that's the first round of
the example we will fix that
okay
okay
and what's this plot theme name labeled
i mean that no
whatever why doesn't it
okay so
and this isn't even looking like a tree
okay so this is showing basically
given node one
it shows everything that is
reachable as a tree from that node is
that correct
um yes but the the parent is usually the
unique part to that child
they say
what if there isn't a unique path
well if it's a what if it's a
multi-graph
[Music]
but then there is no the you know the
immediate denominator is just appearing
above like you see an example so if
there is
if it's not unique is the parent above
so it kind of will come back to the you
know the main road per se
yeah i mean i think it's i think it's a
property like if you look at the the
details above right it says i think it's
a property of what it means to be a
dominator right that there is a unique
path
exactly
okay
and is that the useful thing i mean what
what is the usefulness here
is that that you know the dominator tree
i mean it's it's applying you know when
people use compiler and and other stuff
so it's kind of the usual
the usual constructor when you know you
look at that
sorry say that again i mean so so i've
got some random graph i mean let me let
me make a random graph here
look at the applications there should be
applications
oh well i can't guarantee that we work
on the application yet
extinction of species and trophic models
natural loop detection
when i when it said a host i was
confused and thinking about server
computation
um by the way i mean if it always does
return a tree is there is there also a
dominator tree function which returns a
tree object instead of a graph object
or should there be
seems interesting
why
because we have a whole
system for dealing with trees but maybe
maybe you just say graph tree
you say graph tree of dominated tree
graph
of whatever
i mean you certainly could but i mean if
the function always returns a tree and
we have a special way of representing
trees that might be worth it well the
question is what do people no no no no
we have special ways representing trees
within the graph framework no no that's
not the point the point is what are
people going to use this for what is the
what is the workflow around a dominator
tree graph i think we need to do
applications then
this is
this is this is one of these things we
can even pull it now if we don't feel
it's not sort of mature
i want to see applications this is what
determines that because this is taking
the same options it says as tree graph
which is turning a tree into a graph
no okay tree graph tree graph is an old
it's an old function in the graph
framework
that's a great it also turns a tree into
a graph doesn't it
yes we we added it after you know three
was introduced
i mean we have to fundamentally make a
distinction between a three and three
graph right three tends to more
represented three you know using nested
expression like in the wolfram language
where there is a general concept of
three which is you know an abstract
three which doesn't matter the
representation from double linked lists
to the world from language
right
so
just know that
i agree i agree graph a graph tree so to
speak
i'm getting my my
a tree as represented in graphs has less
data for example it doesn't have
ordering at every node
right
right yes
right and that information doesn't
really exist in this case right there is
no ordering you can't have multiple
copies of the same vertex et cetera
right
right in term of name yes
yeah so so right okay so i guess
there's a there is a reason why this
this should be a graph
fine okay so now
okay what is immediate dominator list
so immediately the nato is just
essentially give the list of predecessor
right so usually you can represent a
three
but you can represent a three by just
giving for a given vertex is predecessor
which is kind of this the syntax we use
for three graph right you give a list
and then we map to the predecessor so
that's one way or we can actually
construct the full three which is what
dominator three does
sorry i'm confused here what is the
difference between in component what how
does how does this list
one one two two two so what does that
mean so that's the list of so the vert
so if you do vertex list of that graph
right yeah and you you you know you just
put this so so for the the vertex at
position one
his predecessor will be one vertex at
position two will be position
predecessor will be one and so on so is
that a representation of the truth using
you know the predecessor list
but i understand this this one here
number five
right or number five why is number five
dominated by vertex 2.
like you asked earlier why there is no
unique path except from two so that way
is dominated by two instead of you know
three and four
because there is two parts
getting to five at least yeah two parts
get into five i see
so this is the unique
this is kind of the pivot point
to get to the rest of the graph
that the point that's the i understand
what this is now that that's the thing
that you have to go through that's the
bottleneck basically
yep
maybe we should use the term bottleneck
somewhere in the description
does that make sense
um yeah
i mean that seems to be the intuitive
thing that's going on yes
am i confused in some way
no no it's kind of that you know the
vertex such that every part goes to it
so
so it depends on the type of application
right so
in some cases you actually see it as a
bottleneck it's you know if that guy's
sorry i'm sorry the application is is it
about where is the bottleneck that gets
you to five what is the most what is the
immediate bottleneck before vertex 5
correct
um yes
that's what this is
where does the terminology are you sure
there's no other field that has another
terminology for
i can't guarantee this they cover all
fields but
that's uh
maybe some other area discover it and we
name it differently that's possible
so
okay so there's it seems like that the
term dominator
let's see so what one is getting
i mean isn't there a better to look
these are vertices right
yes dominator vertex list
yep that's really work
that's the list of dominator vertices
as opposed to
just vertex list so it would typically
look like
well let's just think about that so this
vertex list is a list of the vertices
and dominator vertex list
that seems to me sensible
okay
okay
and now
okay
why are we saying tree graph here as
opposed to just dominate a graph
oh because we tend to
you know
in earlier like you know
find spamming three we kind of try to
you know
include three when the output is a three
i'll have this three times okay fair
enough
except we don't want to call this
dominator tree
because
it isn't a tree in our sense of tree
yes
okay
but we still have fine spanning tree
right
yes which is not a tree in our current
sense of tree right yes
what is it it's a graph in our in our
current sense
yes
oh god look at this horrifying thing
whatever
i hate this i really hate this
or whatever
um
i mean the natural name will be
dominator tree but for the fact that
okay and there's a unique one obviously
yes there's a unique bottleneck of this
kind
okay
well all right dominated tree graph is
probably okay
um
interesting functionality actually now
that i understand what it is
what is a dominating set
isn't that what this dominating vertex
list is
what's the difference between that and a
dominating set
um
also there seems to be a notion of post
dominators
i think the dominator set was
i i don't know recall clearly on my mind
but i think it was related more in terms
of adjacency or vertices than anything
else
oh there's a completely different thing
just a dominating set yeah it's a
completely different thing
which is not a dominator it's a
dominating set which is a completely
different thing yes and related to
independent vertex set on such
right
okay what about post domination
um says the reverse
yes
um
that post is an after a post is in a
meal
ghost doesn't after
uh it just means the things where
everything has to go through that
bottleneck on exit
as opposed to going going through that
bottleneck to get to a node
right
is there actually a function that that
actually does that like a graph reverse
or something like that where it just
takes every directed edge and directs it
there is a reverse graph right isn't
that yes yes okay
so you're suggesting that the post
dominator be found by doing reverse
graph
so maybe i guess yeah
but we should check that that actually
is correct that that works and we should
give an example so people can search for
a post-dominating set first dominator
sorry post-dominate war
um yes he was implanted
okay and that doesn't there's no sense
of saying comma after or something after
the node
you know saying g v
you know the vertex comma after also
what would happen if you want multiple
vertices
by the way this is not right
this oh yes yes it is i'm sorry
this is
wait a minute
starting from that node
right okay that's right but could you
not start from multiple root nodes
um no i guess
this is a deterministic basically
there's a deterministic flow of control
by the way for goodness sake mention the
term flowchart on this page
oh it does say that
okay
i'm just surprised that there aren't
things in you know the land of gantt
charts and so on where people have
talked about this type of thing
roger do you know about that i'm not
sure i don't recognize this name but
this is
a building block on top of which you
build a ton of other things in compiler
analysis i know about compile i mean i
mean i understand about the compiler
analysis case i'm asking about the case
some project management
flow yeah and you're asking you know
there's usually a critical path is what
you uh
right what is the relationship during a
critical path and a dominator
tree
i don't know the critical i know what a
critical path is
um which probably all everybody else
here knows too
that is the one that will dominate the
timeline
right
but this is clearly a related thing
because everything has to go through
that node
i think this
let's look this up okay i mean i these
functions are okay maybe we can make
them experimental if we're not sure
about the relationship to like critical
path stuff and so on
makes
sense
right
okay let's continue looking
graph we talked about making it from
molecule and tree expressions so do we
have any options when they're being made
from no
that's there cannot be any options to
control conversion in that case then we
need a separate function if there's sort
of detail control it needs to be a new
function
okay well so for a molecule a double
bond is just a single connector a single
edge right right
i think we talked about this last time a
bit we did yeah okay did we see an
example of the of the um
data structure conversion
um no i haven't yet built this okay
but pretty much it will be similar if
you open for example the binary tree you
usually have visualizations i think we
do we've already looked at this well i
don't know why we're going back to this
we were on to the geometry section yes
okay
let's not confuse ourselves
um
two graphs functions that somebody's
asking in our live stream
realize
that leaves are submissive to the right
kind of dominant tree
that might be a pun or it might be a
serious piece of um
whatever i'm not sure you know ethan is
commenting with the wrong group of
people to talk about that that uh can
our xml importer should be updated to
turn xml into trees
i completely agree and i think that's
the killer use case for trees
right who is which group is is dealing
with that
that would be
the tree group
are you sure do they know that not the
import export group
i i don't know i don't think anybody is
particularly assigned to xml i think
that's one of those where we've had
people work on it and i don't know that
there's okay well fine but i think it'd
be fine for the tree people so to speak
that sounds wrong doesn't it yeah it
does sound wrong
to um
no but that's a really good suggestion
and i think that that's the killer
driver
application for trees
well along with look i don't know
whether we've got text structure for
example i don't know whether text
structure yet supports a genuine tree
output
um who's who's project managing or
taking notes
brady's here i was just looking at
shoddy's import export formats list and
xml seems to be assigned to john fultz
but either way i'll send this i'll send
this to that that's crazy
yeah
i understand i'm just reporting what i
mean i think it's because json was the
key developer
oh okay so i probably just went up
anyway i'll send this to the right
because i think the two issues are
um
you know text structure
uh
is there a way to get a tree out of this
there should be
and generally our abstract syntax tree
stuff and by the way another person
connected this is chris cooley with his
what's currently in the function
repository the code structure function
repository entry
okay
right which is the thing that takes c
code for example and makes abstract
syntax trees from it
it should be rather easy to turn this
into a tree thing and i think the tree
developers should look at it yeah we
need yeah okay yes i agree but uh we
need to scale it a little bit
the tree effort if that's one person
doing all that it's going to be slow
well it's going to get specialized but
the first thing is just to see how it
flows how the xml and ast stuff flows
into trees
then go from there
okay
um
there was a
comment here about
control
flow graphs
back edges okay
control flow graphs and
i don't know that all the stuff about
cyclomatic complexity and all these
kinds of things that are to do with
essentially um
flow you know flowchart type graphs
yeah i i think that's sort of where
we're going here but
um
okay
let's let's um let's jump to this
okay solid region
okay let me pull up the documentation
page you really want to open in
prototype if you're using 12 3 for the
i don't know whether this
okay there we go
hopefully
right
okay
magnificent so we've been waiting a long
time for this
so a solid region
what about just a single solid region i
don't understand
that
well actually in principle if you
disregard the first usage the first use
is just a convenient way but essentially
you have to specify the boolean
operation which is you know intersection
difference or union
followed by the list of regions
where you apply that
so the first case there is just i don't
understand we've got region union why is
that not just working on solid regions
it is it is working now it's working all
since we shipped right because there is
the distinction here that basically
solid this solid region is
a way it's a representation of regions
as you know intersections and unions and
so on of other regions as opposed to
region union region intersection which
takes you know some meshes and produces
a new mesh is that
the distinction
yes um yes plus actually here uh you
know we assume here the objects are
closed so that means also the
operational
regularize or close operation so if you
make the difference of two objects
the result will be a
an actual solid closed object
where if you do region difference of two
objects you don't have no guarantee that
it's actually closed
sure okay
it's a solid
you know this is
you are basically saying region union
doesn't quite do the right thing so
let's introduce a new function no no no
where john you know does the writing
everything work perfectly solid region
is just completely different
okay so okay so let's just understand
that so if i take a region union of a
ball and a cuboid for example
what the heck is that
what do you mean it's completely
different i mean what the heck is that
that is the output it's you know the
union of ebola and cuboid yeah and
what's the difference in that and solid
region
of union comma ball comma cuboid in this
case they're exactly the same
will will the solid region evaluate to
boolean region or will their full forms
no so the solid region is a
representation it's
different full form it's it's a solid
regional object
you are
i'm sorry you're doing the same thing
you've done a bunch of times you don't
like the way that region union works so
you're introducing a whole new world of
other things that work in a different
way am i wrong
that's not the correct way so
solid region is it the goal of solid
region is to do competition solid
geometry
right
exactly where our boolean operations are
general abstract mathematical operation
like we usually do to general where you
can't actually do much
right so if you want to really compare
right so here the goal is to introduce
an object
right with a specific goal a specific
handling
right the same as you can always claim
that boolean wage on is just implicit
region i mean there's no point to
introduce mp situation because you can
always represent it that way
i completely don't understand why region
union a ball and cuboid does not return
the same thing
so i just don't understand so that's
what that's automatic visualization as
we do for graph and meshes right so we
plan to do that down the road when we
all the framework is in place to be able
to do that
does it look at full form of the solid
region you just ran
right
but it's just the game of photo
visualization so we just you know we
have that on plan for
boolean operation in general it's a
non-trivial
process
so this thing would visualize the same
way but i don't understand what is the
difference between boolean region and
solid region of union
so i think first of all boolean region
can do more stuff so it can deal with
non-solids
but i still don't necessarily see why
that you know name argument why you
couldn't just use boolean region and
when the arguments happen to be solids
that you
basically do it what solid region does
okay so the first goal of this function
is to do constructed solid geometry so
that means the assumption is that all
the object and whatever you're
manipulating are
solid
so there is no like no lower dimension
right in your operation or what you know
what you actually call regular eyes so
one example which is you know more
obvious to look at if you do
the region difference of two objects you
have no guarantee that the resulting
object is a solid object
right
so that's one example where there is a
difference
that's quite magnificent that that works
so if i take that thing and i say volume
of that
we haven't yet implemented all that you
are working on that
okay but that will work at some point
um
for 13
yes should be
okay
magnificent
okay so i'm still completely confused
okay so if i do region okay so let's say
that i do region difference
of ball comma cuboid right
okay now i say graphics 3d of that
reason
of that
oh really confusing
okay
so now i've got this kind of weird
judicized thing
okay which is lower tech than this
beautiful thing here right but it's the
same but lower tech
no it's not the same visually is the
same right because there is right now we
don't um
have a way to display open set so where
you have the cut there of the cuboid
right you don't have actually that face
it's on you know
so okay you shouldn't run volume of
percent 10 because okay here's the point
right
there are many different internal
representations actually you can even
see it in the full form there are many
different representations of regions
right and and you know which have
totally different
you know stored in totally different
ways right so boolean region is one way
of representing a region and when you
just run region on it it basically is
just discretizing it and making a
visualization so when you say something
like volume you know there's going to be
a different implementation of volume for
every different type of region right so
it's going to be implementation for
boolean region and for solid region and
so on
it's a solid region so solid region is
just another uh
another
back-end representation of this but i
guess maybe one question would be i mean
should functions like region union or or
region intersection when the arguments
are solid regions
uh
should it should it just return a solid
region object or should it return
a boolean region
what does that do now so well it's
returning
right now
no so
what you know at least from a point of
view region difference and such are
operations right so if you take mesh
region and you operate on mesh region
region difference and and such do the
right operation and try to remain in
that subsystem of meshes
so if you manipulate solid region with
also to preserve and return you are not
put in that
system we have but but this didn't
define a subsystem this region
difference just said i've got a ball and
a cuboid i want the region difference of
them no way did i say mesh it or
anything weird like that that's just
historical because you happen to
implement that a few years ago
no no i mean we you know if you take a
ball on the cuboid you make the
difference we don't have an object to
represent it in the system beside
boolean way jump under solid region of
difference comma whatever
right we can also represent it as solid
region that's true that's one way
so
but maybe that's what i guess the
question is yeah right i mean is there
any reason no but in this case region
union yes but regional difference cannot
be a solid job that's the thing
because that object is not closed
it's not the you know
because you make a difference that means
that the boundary when you actually cut
you remove that cuboid
those points
this is an open sets question
is that what yeah yeah so okay actually
i mean i i don't
we haven't brought this up charles but
when we do the boolean operations right
now
we intended to eventually have an option
that
controls whether you do regular closed
operations or not
and for right now the only thing we do
are regular closed operations
yes and no what do you mean we went down
to that part i mean it makes the whole
system complicated
intuitively in terms of usability if
somebody take two mesh on the written
mesh he assumed that the result would be
a mesh object
right we can make the whole system
complicated by saying an option
regularized operation or not regularized
okay hold on hold on there's a much
simpler case which is just intervals
right this notion of closed and open
intervals we don't have
i mean you know what we're dealing with
if i it's more than open close regular
closed operation means that you take the
interior and then you take the closure
so that means if you have the the you
know just as a lower dimensional thing
will be blown away completely
there's nothing left
okay so what you're saying is if i make
an inequality let's say that i'm
asking a question is a point
inside this region and i have a point on
the boundary let's say for example here
right i say um is the
center of the cube
zero zero zero
in the thing or not
is that an example of a question that
would be that would matter whether this
issue would matter
well yes but it's not the quintessential
example because that the only thing that
matters in your case is open closed it's
not the regularity pit
you know it's it's it's okay so what
you're saying is if i take the ball
and i
uh how do i get the the boundary of the
ball
in in this constructive soul geometry
thing how would i get this what's that
boundary region
boundary
okay
oh for god's sake how is anybody
supposed to remember that
region okay that's right it's operating
on a region region boundary
of a sphere
right that should be
i take that
i get that lovely
okay and that has if i say what's the
volume of that
it will say zero
what
why is it saying that
because it's not defined
what does that mean because it's sphere
is just the
oh
it's it's the is the surface there is no
pesetum or volume yes we can return zero
but it's it's not defined
why is it not defined it's defined and
it's zero isn't it
what do you mean if you actually ran
it would be zero right
i mean it's the same like say volume of
a point
which is zero
the surface area of a point is zero two
yep
okay we can't switch that i think so i
mean i i don't know you you tell me but
i think i mean
you know what what would adam say about
that for example
from from the point of view of algebraic
geometry and so on
the consistent thing to do is just say
it's zero
i think i mean perhaps i'm wrong
as far as i know it's you know those
operations like region measure those
oppression are defined on the object
based on dimensionality of the object
right so when you have a an object
dimension three you can talk about
volume but when an object is on the
lower dimension
that concept doesn't exist
well but you can also i mean this
yes two things first there's the the
question of the embedding space maybe
but but also this sphere is uh like
not the business
the dimensionality of the object
right but this sphere has you know is it
like topologically yes right or like
it is a two-dimensional it's like a
two-dimensional manifold right but it is
you know quotes a three-dimensional
object right in the sense that it's
points are a subset of you know r3 or
something
right
it's a look the issue is is volume
referring to the embedding space or is
it referring intrinsically to the object
itself it's referred because it's
referring to the dimension of the object
okay then then i could give an argument
for why it should sound defined
okay for sphere though i think i mean
for point i i i i agree but i think
sphere though i mean given that
it does seem like it is a
three-dimensional object because it is a
subset of r3
yeah i mean we would probably
we went to that that part of send
undefined because you know you have
arc lengths you know surface area and
all those you know concepts which are
defined on that dimension of the object
than just on the full space otherwise
you'll just say well
somebody give you an object of
20 dimension the volume is zero somebody
gives you an object of zero dimension a
point it's also zero
yeah all right fair enough okay i'm i'm
buying into this i mean although it will
be good to make sure we explain that
this is that this represents
the intrinsic thing not the thing i mean
that may be worthwhile at some point to
have a wrapper here that says a ball you
know a thing embedded in
three-dimensional space
as opposed to this object itself because
this object itself
is a 2d manifold
am i making sense
as opposed to
a
thing embedded in three-dimensional
space
i think there's a distinction between
those things
for our purposes
yes that makes sense
yes
so we we may need that distinction
we may need
um
you know
something like
i don't know space embedded that's a bad
name but okay let's let's go back to
this question right so i'm completely
not getting this
completely not getting this i don't
think it makes sense all right so let's
go through this
again so
to me region union should give me the
reach the union of those regions why
does it why is it not doing that why do
i have another thing here that does that
they both do it one auto visualizes the
other one doesn't
that's not an adequate answer that's
simply not inadequate so
solid the goal of solid region is to be
able to do compulsory solid geometry so
essentially giving a set of closed
object ball
and whatever object torres and such we
should be
able to manipulate them and do boolean
operation essentially three fundamental
boolean operational intersection defense
and union
and also obtain back those objects so
there is a the same as we have mesh
right there is a subsystem right
where the whole thing is consistent
because mesh essentially is a union of
polygon
but we can also claim that we don't need
to introduce mesh
right region union of polygon will also
cover mesh but we introduce that
subsystem because you can actually live
in it do operations in a consistent way
okay
so that's the case
i mean i want to know what is region
union supposed to return why is it not
returning one of these csg regions
basically
why is it returning a boolean region
rather than a csg region
we can probably do that later on we you
know
you know this will introduce are
introducing celebration on this release
right boolean region was introduced uh
years ago when we're doing
you know when we introduce region union
and boolean region is that general
abstract representation because the
first argument of boolean region you can
actually give any boolean function
right
so is that you know general abstract
boolean operation
you know which is kind of too general
and actually there is no in principle
hope that it you know you can actually
compute anything you know which out of
boolean region so so what what is the
like decision process i mean is it like
or like if i'm trying to decide hey
should i be using solid region or
boolean region assuming that it is
possible to use solid region
right i mean what
is there a case where i could use solid
region but i'm actually going to prefer
boolean region
um no actually the goal is you know if
you want to do modeling you want to
build
an object you use solid region because
you can easily take you know like that
illustration there you can actually
construct object
you know easily by using solid region by
using intersectional difference let's
see if i can cut through all of this
basically you have two different
representations
for solid geometry one of them is in
terms of meshes where you break
everything down
to
what is it is it is it uh
is it surface meshes or is it tetrahedra
or something
what what is the what is the mesh
structure for a sphere that sphere i got
what is the the ball i should say what
is the mesh structure for a ball
so
it we have two two okay
so so and it depends on your application
the simplest representation is what's
called a boundary representation and
that's a boundary mesh
that just represents the boundary
surface
if you need the internal structure like
in finite element and other places you
need to have an in
an internal mesh in which which case
it's typically
tetrahedralized
or broken down into smaller sub-regions
for which one can solve problems
but at the end those two objects are
roughly speaking the same but just
different representation
actually i mean this is sort of a maybe
a
this is a very it's too late to ask this
question by many years but is there a
particular reason why like you know in
the graph functions you know there are a
couple different underlying
representations but they're all hidden
inside of graph but in the region
functions they're all exposed i mean is
it just that they're sufficiently
different in the region functions that
it's worth
making them more visible
yeah
because you get this there's things that
make sense for a mesh that makes no
sense elsewhere like there's a natural
graph structure for a mesh
and you we even have something called
mesh connectivity graph that gives you
all that
those things
those notions of edge and face and those
things makes no sense for any other
representation than a mesh
representation
um
maybe christopher is asking more about
like for graph you have to pass a
representation double linked list and
such is it what you're asking no no
look the continuum
we have represent we have the continuum
which is what's going on here this is
the thing that is you know
hook line and sinker continuum whereas
as soon as we've meshed it
we're not continuum anymore
is that a fair way to put it
no
because that's intended to approximate
the continuum but but i understand that
but but you just said yes connectivity
graph yeah these kinds of things they
are admitting the fact that a mesh is
not the continuum exactly and people
talk about them people talk about
polygon as if they are real things in
polyhedra
and they they do very low resolution
ones do you know what i'm saying i i
know but so that hence my point that
conceptually the difference here is
between
thinking about space
as in some kind of discrete
approximation and thinking about it
genuinely as the continuum where we have
a purely symbolic representation that is
just the continuum representation and
just to build on what christopher asked
about sort of the design that i
envisioned for this at the region level
not at the sub-region level like mesh
regions and stuff at the region level
we can have many more representations
and the whole thing is built to support
uh multi-representation so for instance
um we're gonna do non-linear meshes
effectively which is sort of a
representation that they have in cad
systems they're called boundary reps and
uses nurbs
um to represent the surfaces and so on
so that's an important type of
representation
a little bit later in the future we
might get to something called
subdivision regions which are popular in
the movie industry yeah yeah i
understand where you're where you're
doing adaptive meshing and things
yeah we're doing adaptive meshing anyway
but but subdivision region are basically
defined as limits of a subdivision
scheme
oh okay
okay but so let's let's zoom out again
for a second okay
so in this case here
for whatever reason this thing chose to
use the mesh representation for this
region
no what what's happening no that's just
visualization steve just visualization
and it's
you know you have to okay okay fine so
in the future we might have better
visualizations yes
in fact we didn't tell you this but
under the hood it's effectively using
ray tracing that's why it's looking so
damn good it's using gpu shaders on your
system
uh and it's using ray tracing in this in
the 3d case
okay that's cool and we are going to
reuse that framework to actually handle
this one correctly that's you know okay
when you say region difference
the question is
this
is one this is one you know is there an
identity boolean region of this is equal
to yes solid
should be of difference or whatever well
i mean it comes into the slightly subtle
thing that charles kind of hinted to
which we haven't fully resolved which is
lower-dimensional no no in this case
it's not even subtle they are completely
do two different
results region difference you will move
the point we haven't settled that
whether whether this one should do that
or not okay this is about lower
dimensional subspace yes right okay fine
okay so what
no i'm confused this is a state
operation you remove the point yes we
can complement it by regularization but
it's clear that you remove the point
okay but charles charles the difference
between these things so what we're
saying is i mean you see this is what's
interesting is
you know what we need we need an almost
almost equal operation no no look look i
i know i know i know stephen i know
right this is the continuum meets the
discretums right but that's what i'm
kind of saying is that two different
kinds of equals is it's like almost
equal whereas say a magician would say
it's equal almost everywhere or
something
well but but look look the point is we
crossed the bridge of saying
two the precise two is equal to two the
approximate to here right okay
okay what you are claiming is that for
regions
you don't want to do that
right and that makes sense
right so if i say here
two is less than two point
okay that's interesting
yeah
that's an interesting claim
i'm going to save this file because i
want to
isn't that what you expect
if they're equal then you expect that
two is less than two points can be false
right
well is that true that that's that it is
always the case that
um
i don't know the calculus of this i mean
with floating point numbers it's not
obvious
what two do do two is greater than two
points also going to say false because
they're equal
okay fair enough
fair enough so it's logic is if they're
equal they've got to be strictly they
cannot be strictly less than yeah okay
fine but so what we're doing here is
what you're saying is
that
the
the csg region difference
is the symbolic thing that is like the
two here
in some sense
the they're both they behoove like the
exact actually all right okay fine fine
well the i mean we could we could do an
analogy here with with uh intervals an
interval intersection and so on do we
have an interval complement if we did we
will be thrown right into this issue
right yeah we don't
actually i mean out of curiosity because
it might already be implemented what
happens if you say region equal of these
two things
exactly
well i mean right now i think we're not
fully implemented anyways but but
charles is arguing for that should be
false
which i don't think we're ready
we're gonna have some more arguing to do
that
and that because if you said region
member
then you gave it like zero zero zero
would give a different answer
just open the documentation of region
difference and ready to give the
definition
that will tell you what will be the
output
without regularization or anything it's
it's a set operation yes
and it's a compliment or something right
but here's the issue that we've been
struggling with you know because we
think that the vast majority like 99
percent of people
want regularized operation for solids
um because what does regularized mean
again it means you take the interior and
then you take the closure of the result
and if you look at the second example in
the 3d case there you have two mesh by
the cuboid and the cone
we actually return you a mesh because
it's here that we actually do that
regularization otherwise mathematically
is not correct you don't have that
boundary
well there's that too yes right yes what
are you talking about so you mean by not
having the boundary you mean
if i take the region difference and then
i ask about a point on the cone
that that point on the cone should not
be present in the region difference is
that correct correct
but but now it will sell say it is
because what because you're doing this
regularization no because i mean at
least the logic right now at least for
me was that you know when you're in the
mesh sub system you have you know
dealing with mesh
meshes measures can cannot can can only
meshes are closed exactly you know
polyhedra are closed polygons are closed
they can't deal with some faces mission
missing
i mean maybe they could like maybe maybe
you could have some way of marking
basically mesh cells and saying this is
an open mesh cell but that means right
but the close of the train train's
closed in a different sense i mean a
polyhedron that's closed it's it's like
does it let water in
it's a closed set yeah
an inclusive boundary
right now
so
i mean this is the look this is a
question with intervals it's a question
with these things
does
the thing include its boundary
right and so ball for example
presumably includes its boundaries yes
it's documented yes okay could i get a
ball that has been skinned that doesn't
include its boundary if so how would i
do it could i do region difference of
ball comma sphere
well no i think there's two issues here
right i mean i think the point is like
potentially right there could be a
version of ball that when you ask these
sorts of questions it sort of behaves
like an open ball right as opposed to a
closed ball but the issue is that
you know for example if that function
like like region difference if it's
going to return a mesh region that right
now there's no way of representing you
know open faces as in as in an open set
uh in a mesh region and so it's sort of
like uh and and this is the same with a
couple other types of representations
too so so it's sort of like uh
it's hard for these functions to be
totally consistent about how they handle
open and closed sets because sometimes
they're returning representations that
can't represent open sets
that's kind of the point okay
yeah okay so the question is could there
be a skinned mesh so to speak that has
had that
aka open but that's a confusing way i
mean it's just a confusing thing that is
something which does not include its
boundary
we say yes but is it needed in the
system does it yeah yeah but the other
thing is that you need to be able to
sort of add and remove everything you
know every point every edge every face
everything well you're saying you could
have a sphere which is mostly includes
its boundary but has one point at the
pole for example the north pole is not
included for example for example what
and white non-bullion region represent
all that
what do you mean but represent so so in
this case here
for example could i ask
okay do we have a function that answers
the question is this a closed set
no
but we could couldn't we
yes
then that might be useful in
understanding what's going on
so so the the thing is this we we're
threading a fine line here between sort
of complexity of representation
uh usefulness
um
you know and do-ability kind of yeah i
know i know okay
welcome to our world yeah yeah well
yes right we just have to be careful on
this one because this is this is exactly
the same type of issue as this right we
could have made the decision that those
two things are unequal that would have
been silly
i mean okay so
again this question of is it open or
closed there's a
okay so you're saying region difference
does this thing that produces
this accurately represents whether this
is open or closed if i were to do this
as solid region what would i get here so
if i say
um
the the seemingly
indistinguishably different operation
but bizarrely with different synthetics
no solid region doesn't take a sphere
solid region all the regions manipulator
close by jumps yeah it's solid all the
way
it needs to be solid opera you know
arguments
enclosed you use cuboid instead of
ball i mean even if you just want to see
the difference you can just try
you know the difference between a ball
and a cuboid and the difference between
you know and use region number on zero
zero zero right
yep right and if you do that region
member on the boolean boolean region we
see that you will tell you you know one
comma zero zero is not the point of that
region
i know solid region doesn't yet work on
that
i it say false
you know we are still implementing so i
cannot do that okay
it's just a bug or something but but if
you try boolean region
yeah without 18 you should
without 18 you should probably take one
comma zero zero
and hopefully it will tell you false
okay so region member
percent eighteen
zero zero zero right uh no one zero zero
right so you're
okay
whereas
okay but we have no representation of
one minus epsilon
no
and just to you know
i mean this is oh gosh welcome to the
crazy world of the continuum i mean it
seems like this is sort of i mean the
basic point is that there's some pure
math
there's some pure math and sort of
topology related usages we care about
this but everywhere else you don't
but also the point 99 is more of a
numerical computation issue where the
one we are talking about is more a
topological issue right
no i know part of the complement of
i know
okay so let's let's zoom out for a
second here okay
so the first issue is
you have a particular representation of
regions
this csg representation is a nice clean
representation
that
perhaps makes some slightly different
assumptions about
regularization well it is i mean i
actually know that i think about it it
is the clean
uh regularized operations
and then we can actually then we don't
have to have this potential hack that
i've been worried about for years for
for the region the other region
operations
so walk me through that again
so um when we did the original design of
boolean operations i had these two
worries
that is that the 99 of people don't care
about the subtleties that you've been
asking about
because what they want is exactly this
they want csg operation they want to
create shapes you know they want to you
know like like clay basically
right and
and the thing is that but mathematically
speaking that's just plain wrong that's
not what boolean operations do if you
define them raw
so the way that what people figured out
then in the cad world
that modeled this for engineering
systems and other things
is that you should do the correct thing
to do was to do what's called regular
closed operations which means that you
take the interior of the result and then
take the closure that means if the
result was lower dimensional there is
nothing left and if the result
you know had some you know some open
missing some some faces or some you know
some surface pieces that will be added
in that will be
closed and and filled in
yep
and that made for
a pretty good model but then they ran
into trouble
uh
well let me skip the trouble bit
okay but anyway so
but bottom line is that we haven't
defined we have been vague about what we
do
because we wanted to strike that up but
we knew it's going to take several
rounds of development to be able to live
up to that to do both
you know to basically have some kind of
option to specif
specifies whether you do a regularized
operation or not
because we also wanted a boolean
operation to solve other key problems
like surface surface intersection in 3d
or ray surface intersection
yeah you know and i think that those are
very key and we don't want sort of 15
other functions that solve you know
here's the surface surface function
surface surface intersection function
here's a ray surface all right
bottom line it seems to me that region
right now if region could get some
specification of whether it thinks it's
regularized or not
and then there's contagion about
regularization through the operations
that something like that could work
can i add something i i don't know if
you you forget but we discussed this
right so if you open the page of region
difference for example right the way we
decided to go was with subsystem right
where we said
the region difference of two um boundary
mesh regions give you the smallest
bonder in measured jump so we do
implicitly that's just realization
that's based on this right
that covers that up yes right okay so
hold on hold on so here's a here's a
suggestion okay
so
basically the idea is the region itself
carries the information about whether it
is intending to be a regularized region
no
no that's in that's in the boolean
operation
wait wait wait wait wait wait wait i'm
saying let's imagine that that was the
case okay let's imagine like like closed
and open intervals which are not
you know putting that but we need to do
that
you know we need to do that with ball
and all kinds of things primitives yes
we would need to do that yes we would
need to do it let's just walk through
this for a second okay assume that there
was an option that basically said
whether it was regularized or not
and assume that regions knew that
whether they were intended to be
regularized or not
okay then
they you know all these operations like
region difference etc well okay so the
first question is when you do a region
difference on a ball and a cube
what should it do should it use
salt should it use construction solid
geometry or should it use
and the answer is seems to me that's an
implementation detail that's not
something you should stick the user's
nose into as far as the user is
concerned what it can return it could be
this it could be some slightly different
representation doesn't really matter
it's a symbolic representation that then
allows you to compute from it but it
certainly shouldn't be the case but then
then the decision about which of those
it uses is largely automatic and it
might make a particular choice if it can
tell that all regions involved are
intended to be regularized it might
decide to do one thing rather than
another
right
go ahead right it's actually properly
speaking what we are doing now
all right and it's what i was pointing
in that page that we kind of implicitly
said for you know mesh boundary mesh and
uh mesh region and you see that in you
know in all those pages we said you know
for mesh and boundary mesh this is the
result because you hopefully see
when you're in that subsystem for the
type of mesh we want to realize
operation but when you deal with you
know graphic primitive and such right we
associate them close to you know algebra
white pin a ball is you know x square
plus you know
sorry so we preserve we preserve that
structure where it's kind of a state
theoretical thing
right so that means if you do you know
implicit region
and you know the efficient operation of
a ball and then you use the actual
assembled ball we give you the same
result but the implicit representation
is x squared plus y squared z squared
less than or equal to one is that
correct yes
so if i said less than one what would i
get
you have another open object it's not a
ball so that means when you do those
even you do region difference on that
the resulting implicit region you
actually see that the inequality is
preserved the output is preserved
we preserve the fact that it's open
okay fine but you're saying in the case
of constructed solar geometry you would
not do that is that correct
so i did the same thing if i took an
implicit region and i said the csg
region of my ball created by a strict
inequality
in an implicit region and did the exact
same operation what would happen
would this give zero would this give the
null set or what would it do um so first
is because um solid region actually will
restrict you that you cannot actually do
that so
solid
solid region just takes some you know
the list is you know it's down there
it's a specific set of lists so you
cannot actually even express it in that
context
okay fine fine so so this is essentially
a
i mean if i were to think about this in
terms of algebra for example this is
like oh you usually use elliptic
functions but in this particular case it
can be represented as a square root this
is sort of a special function
of
uh you know this is a representation of
of a
a region as a special function of
regions is that a fair way to
characterize it
i mean it seems like it's just it's just
you know
it will
it for example a function like region
difference will try to the extent that
it can to have its output in the same
representation as its inputs and some
inputs are capable of representing
whether they're open and closed and some
aren't
so it's more just a question of you know
region difference just has to know for
every type of input or maybe
the user has to sort of know for every
type of input does this you know given
the output type that i'm probably going
to get in this input type and by typing
like the type of representation
you know is that output type going to be
able to represent open sets if yes then
i can expect that they'll be correct if
no then you know right of course there
isn't going to be any so i'm completely
not buying into the fact that these are
two different operations
i mean i don't understand why you know
to me this region difference thing at
best is a method option that determines
to know
we can perfectly well have a special
purpose csg function there's nothing
wrong with that but in terms of what
region difference does it seems to me it
should be able to return both of those
no no that's fine i mean there is no uh
you know i mean i have no position on
that uh you know really
you know the point was more like you
know we're introducing solid region for
a certain goal is you know
to do solid constructive geometry like
in cat system and social social point
out right so if later on when we
propagated in the system and it happened
that
you know
regional difference you know we need to
generate boolean region also literally
that's you know
you know from a point of view of our
framework it doesn't matter it's just a
representation of the same geometric
object and the system should handle it
so
so region difference can return boolean
regions so lead region and even implicit
region we actually do that right now so
they are all the same
so we just pick the one which is more
appropriate for the subsequent
operations
uh sorry please go on yeah that's it
says again i i lost that i got
distracted by something
um could you say that again
no saying that i mean um regional
different and you know subsequent
function in the geometry framework
can return boolean regions
you know that that's fine i mean you
know the whole sub system is built that
way
right and that was not you know it's not
that representation which is actually
this you know the main goal here here
you know solid region i mean we push to
introduce it because it allows us to do
conceptually geometry as well as
represent all you know objects coming
from cat system and such
but it is
right but it should be transparent i
mean in other words if i say this name
is just not making it
that you know it's not the general solid
region region general solid region
this is a specific representation just
like a boundary mesh representation or
any of these other i think it should
maybe
csg region might be a better name
actually
just just for the fun of it when you say
is not really the solid region what do
you mean
i can prove that also this region like
equivalence to that but that's no i
realized that but what i'm saying is in
our system what i meant was
that the generic way to represent a
region
um
is
you know is the region you know is the
region wrapper and the region rapper
already knows it has multiple different
internal representations
depending on whether it's an approximate
mesh or whether whatever so there are
two different issues one is what is its
internal representation which in the
case of graph
you have very successfully hidden that
from the user and the user doesn't care
right
in in the case of it's
it's relative because in term of graph
we have pad graph we have three graphs
it's just that
when we went to the design we decided
you know we should just abstract it and
return one object because absolutely
right which is great and it works very
well
okay so for regions
what we're saying is we can't quite do
that
right because because and it's really
because of the the long claw of the
continuum basically
um
you know if the if if we could do things
purely symbolically
we could do that if we wanted to do
things purely symbolically so that they
are effectively represented discretely
then that will be fine the difficulty is
that on in our
non-continuous world we cannot represent
the continuum perfectly
except by virtue of unevaluated
operations
so
you know okay so what we've got is
region is now approximated in various
ways
but it still should be the case that
you know you could not know about any of
that
and you could just use the region
wrapper to represent a region right well
okay at
at the level that there are operations
that we call region operations they
should apply to every possible way that
you can give a reason like region member
really works on everything
okay
the things that are named mesh they work
on mesh things
so mesh connectivity these are things
that apply to sort of that
family of representation just as
we have other special representations
like polynomial it's kind of general but
but you know and it's very useful
but
it's it's not the same as a as a general
function
i'm saying it's a special family of
functions right
you know and we have a whole slew of
operations that work on polynomials
and we have kind of a family of
operations that work on measures
yes i understand and you can convert a
region to a mesh
right
and and that's fine but i'm saying that
region difference better just eat you
know any implicit region or whatever
and
then it does
okay so here
basically
or csg region is more restrictive in
that it takes other csg region as input
or it takes these base primitives
and an original csg was just not quite
solid regions because that's what's
confusing i agree
every meeting we've had now for half a
year i started by saying i really don't
like the name
okay well do we want to call it csg or
do we want to call it
constructed
i think csg is what everybody calls it
that's what i think and it's somewhat
technical and you have to understand
what's going on to use it basically yeah
i think it's a it's a good name
i've gotten used to it by now so it's
like oh yeah this probably should be csg
that's probably right but i mean but
also like
i don't know if there's someone who's
not super technical but is like i'm
trying to design this part for 3d
printing or something like that they
probably do want this but they probably
will be scared away by csg i think they
would know what csg was
but they also won't want this they won't
use this they'll use region difference
on these things and it will return a csg
region they'll never see it because it
will auto auto format
and they'll just be happy right that's
the ideal case i guess yeah right i mean
the fact is that that the the only thing
we're doing here is to reveal the fact
that it is a csg region instead of a
boolean region for example
which is not terrible i think i think
that's probably just as well
we think that these are going to scale
by the way to have hundreds of
primitives in them and build really
complex
um solid regions
is is that scaling i mean
compared to like what's what exists
right now is the issue with scaling
performance or is it like the number of
different types of primitives or what
uh
it's the compute i mean it depends on
what you want to do right now we can't
even
visualize because
discretization
performance is not
well it's not just performance it's it's
a variety of things
um
but these ones you can at least look at
them uh you know even with with hundreds
of primitives
and implicitly when you have a clg3
there is a set of property you know you
don't need to validate
that's one key thing right
so based on that like is the object
closed is the actually just know that
you know is it empty
right
compared to buoyant region where you
actually need to do explicit operation
to know if the result is an empty set or
not
so there is those different
computationally behind the scene
right
okay for the visualization so there is
all those
pre-assumptions you can get from
solitude
um ideally it'll be more performance
eventually
yeah because this this is yeah no that
they'll all be more performant
eventually by the way people are asking
on the livestream why csg and why not
spell it out actually i have a good
reason for not spelling it out which is
these are actually two-dimensional
things and so if you say constructive
solid geometry and they apply to
parallelograms it's kind of crazy oh but
these are 2d solids
perfectly fine they are nd right yeah we
do nd solids
these are 2d solids
roger that is that is disgustingly
incomprehensible no no it's completely
standard nomenclature i i understand
that but that's an argument for using
csg
which people understand to be this kind
of proceed but by the time you use solid
and you're referring to it as a
two-dimensional thing every elementary
math person
hears a solid they think a pyramid a
cone
they do not think a triangle a triangle
is not a solid
yes it is yes but it is but not in
elementary math
you know elementary math is going to get
updated
elementary i think since it's good
for hundreds of years yeah i think the
greeks probably used you know a similar
word to refer to solid geometry but
i'm not sure
yes i mean this has been it's been the
same way for thousands of years roger
the people have made the distinction i
know in euclid there's a completely
separate book about solid geometry oh
the whole literature is come completely
confused between
you know it's like like sometimes they
they say um
they draw just a boundary for a triangle
and they say it's it you know it's okay
roger we're not solving this problem
this has been this way for thousands of
years we're not going to but you know
we're not going to be able to solve this
problem and just by by being persnickety
you know a whale is not a fish type type
thing
um you know we're just going to confuse
people
so i i think that's an argument for
calling it csg
which is a kind of a brand name for this
kind of approach
unless we say i mean
no i i think we all agree stephen we're
all how does this relate to our
synthetic geometry stuff
how does this relate to what we're doing
there
that's a language for talking about
points and intersecting lines right
well on circles oh yeah right and
polygon
well and polygons
so the difference here is
that are you claiming
i mean it has a notion of area for
example the synthetic geometry system
has a notion of area
so now i'm a little bit suspicious
i think we need to understand that
relationship
okay
i mean let's i think it's going to be a
separate discussion with different
people but i think we should do that so
we don't produce something but i think
what what we're understanding here is
this should be csg region
that just like we can have mesh region
there's csg region those are two kinds
of of um of implementations for regions
so to speak does that make sense
yeah
okay
and this whole question of
regularization is a separate question
which we have not properly addressed yet
and these different representations will
at first kind of randomly choose to
regularize or not
so for example in principle region
difference could have some kind of
option that says should you regularize
or should you not and could have a
different target it doesn't really need
a different target because you can
always say mesh region of the output
right right
question if i say csg region could csg
region eat anything other than
primitives
is there ever any output from
uh region operations that can be cast
into a csg region
yes but we want
is the level of complexity so clg region
need to be built on top of essentially
is it three right so is it that
necessary of base primitive
right we can extend it to each implicit
region because you can represent the
ball has an implicit region but that
will
you know define the purpose of actually
introducing solid region i mean clg3 chg
region
all right okay so look i we we need to
rap in a moment here but but um
uh
let me just look ahead here
what's this region convert
what was that before
okay hold on we've got a whole bunch of
new stuff here all right so create data
structure
is these are these are data structure
things these are not top level functions
they are top level functions right
um no just the same as the binary tree
so from the create data structure right
in that sense in that sense yes
so they're just string names in data
structure correct right
and the very fact we're calling that csg
tree
is good resonance for the csg region yes
um
my gosh okay so there's a whole bunch of
new stuff here well wonderful i mean
it's wonderful there's new stuff
ah we're going to need at least another
hour on this right i'll get a schedule i
mean i think we're interested
okay but but the things we're leaving
hanging here
are a little bit on this regularization
of regions right do we think anything is
hanging for this version with respect to
regularization region no no no
okay
and i'm just saying not again on that
right we had it since i don't know
version
10 or such right there never been
initial confusion from the user point of
view oh yes they have i i've been
confused
about these questions of whether things
are in or out of i mean whenever you're
doing things which are elementary math
you get confused with this i have been
confused many times
you're thinking about fancy super fancy
math and super fancy you know industries
no no actually no no
no the definition is documented is
simple it's it's
you think about fancy math it's not
simple if you don't
i mean this this business about okay
okay that that
graph the solid
oh my gosh so that is
so that is that is the equivalent of a
mesh connectivity graph
for a csg
region is that correct
solid region tree graph
is
right that's the equivalent of a mesh
connectivity graph but no no it's the
construction tree if you look at the the
reference page
so that's
that first tree to the left there
that's the tree
which yes a little bit analogous like at
least to the extent that it's like a
mesh is just you take a bunch of points
in the lines you sort of assemble them
in some way and this is you're taking
these other bigger primitives assembling
sure i mean it's like a giant union
it measures that yeah mesh is a giant
union right where every node
in the mesh is a union node
every node in the in the mesh
connectivity graph is a unioning node
right well you know all the primitives
you are using in solid region in cg
trajon there are just cells if you look
at it that way
right but so so the thing that you get
out
oh boy it's a graph how is it a graph
why is why don't you make it an actual
tree
because if you made an actual tree you
could label the nodes by the operations
and then you could actually have it be
the case that that csg region could each
one of those tree objects and produce
the actual region
you know
it's a matter of flavor right i mean i
won't argue with that you know here we
you know we want to map it back to the
graph framework
that's one thing if you want to map it
into three framework now right this is
an expert
no this is an expression right no but i
think we should call it csg region tree
and it should be a tree object the thing
is i mean the distinction we made
earlier right was that that you know
you use graphs for example there's
there's no ordering information
if the nodes aren't repeated or if it's
nonsensical for those to be repeated and
trees are more if you're representing an
expression like thing where you know
right there is ordering the nodes can be
repeated et cetera it seems like this is
a case this is really just a held
expression
you know and the order matters a lot and
the nodes are repeated so
that's why
the tree yes but that's why we have
expression three i mean that that my
thought at the time i mean no this of
this object is an actual you'll be
normal expression
right you just wake up
clg3 will be a normal expert it would be
an expression in the language so if you
apply expression 3 on it
you should actually yeah but cs3 is not
in the language this is part of data
structure no sorry i mean cig
right whereas this for example if this
was a tree with with nodes that were
labeled by union et cetera et cetera
this would be very nice and it will be
if you really want the graph out you
just say tree graph and that will give
you the pure graph where you've dropped
what the node labels are
okay uh i mean i won't argue that is the
amount of flavor between a tree graph on
its way
right i think it should be just because
you built tree graph and other people
built tree does not mean trees should be
you know cast into the outer darkness so
to speak
not at all i mean we we made a full
integration to the tree framework
i know okay okay okay you support trees
plant a tree good okay but i i think
this should be a tree
um
we'll do that
okay
uh i i just i'm i'm because i'm
impatient i just want to know roughly
what's coming up here
um
lovely tauruses okay
um
oh tube is now supported as a geometric
region about time that's good
um
oh boy
that's all complicated but we'll discuss
this
oh my gosh you really have 3d var noise
now
wow
how many times have people asked for 3d
var noise
we didn't think we would get it to be
honest this was um but we have it
well
not yet we are working on it right it's
coming
this is one of those which
i thought a number of times this has
been requested no no we would get it
eventually but we thought we would have
to build a whole new framework so this
is more like oh maybe we found our way
around
this is like since you're a big soccer
fan stephen
this is when you hit the g of course you
are i mean i'm you grew up in soccer
country right
so this is when you hit the goal post
when it hits like the goal post and goes
in
this is
i don't know
it's one of those okay okay well let's
hope that works that will be wonderful
because it has been you know it's it's
one of our top most requested
algorithmic things
so they're in the category or in the
category of voronoi mesh requests
um does this also uh there's also always
been the issue of uh whether the cells
line up with the vertex ids or like the
you know what i mean like the order of
the points that you give that that you
put in whether those align with the
the numbers of the cells you get out
yes we won't say be able to do that
because you need them to run the whole
software so but the plan was i think
roger actually requested to
add a notation to the voronoi yeah so
you can recover the information we
support general annotations for meshes
so we want to provide those annotations
that allow you to do those alignments
sure okay an annotation would be a good
way to do that i mean but
also i mean is there no reason not to
just use the the cell id
but um
well in term of complexity you can
always do that but you know from the
result we need to assault again the
whole thing to just before we give you
an output so
graphic speaking is you know you know
and logan complexity we are adding on
the operation
so well that doesn't sound bad actually
well depends on if you decide
theoretical complexity but it's like
i have to imagine i mean if you're
already getting the if you already can
get the alignment right because you can
add an annotation i have to imagine the
actual computation time of of reordering
the things would be absolutely
infinitesimal compared to you know
computing the actual message not not
really
for the annotation we actually keep
track
right through the whole process so we
actually have the information
right but you can just keep track the
whole time and at the end reorder them i
i don't know i mean it just seems like
it's a matter of calling part which is
generally pretty quick
well
we'll try to see what what we can do can
guarantee that but
as long as we keep the complexity down
all right we've got lots of things to
look at still
this is going to be at least another
solid hour and by solid i don't mean
um
okay
sounds good thanks a lot guys